I really love this season and I
especially love the season 5 premiere
let's jump right into it there's that
spoiler we're gonna talk all about
there's never after the premiere episode
take me back to filming that episode
what was your favorite scene
you know there's it was such a great
episode we shot it for a very long time
I think with seven days or two shooting
that wedding and then we did pick up
honestly it's all kind of blurred
together we did so many takes of that
wedding and we got married about 50
times how many I was 52 wasn't was it 17
or something I think it was 7 but 17
sounds were interesting was a lot yeah
but I feel like because we actually did
the whole wedding in one take not in one
take we didn't many takes of it but we
didn't split it up at all so every time
we did it we ran it from the top to the
bottom and it was it was quite a long
wedding vows we got married so many
times just to make sure that we were
absolutely married we've got married
about 41 times mm-hmm
we started if okay our families our
minds started dating blankly to each
other than this takes yeah but it's
beautiful and it's just like it's a
really special moment you know Clara
never thought she would be able to see
Breanna get married she didn't think
that that that was something that was
going to be possible so those little
moments with with Sophie with Breanna
were really special and and also you
know just I think being the parents of
Breanna and watching her get married was
it was a really special thing for Jamie
and Claire but it was fun it was
actually it's a rare day that we get all
the cast together and one scene as you
know there's so many characters in the
show that when you're all together it's
there was a really vile it was stuff we
had to Kirlian which just felt like
Akili mm-hmm we had some really sweet
scenes between we ate a lot of cake or
jump dance which I'm pretty sure he did
put actual brandy in
yeah I think you may be right so what's
done to feel and attire tipsy after a
little while but we will take a little
yeah yeah it was fun it was really fun
and we were actually really lucky with
the weather I don't think it rained it
was really cold but didn't rain so happy
days Jamie you know he never imagined
you to get to be you know there for his
daughter and I think he's very proud to
give her away and what's it all to go
very well and yeah that that moment
where he takes her you know something
borrowed something blue didn't grumpy
though was me well he just wants it to
be right like he needs the best for his
daughter if there's a little bit of
jealousy like this weird kind of male
thing where he's like uh some other men
it's a bit weird we also had a really
sweet like romance montage in that
episode you guys are five seasons in do
you still get butterflies before big
scenes like that definitely get
butterflies watching it do you really
know that sounds bad actually
butterflies see what it's a group
montage yes interesting yeah that's
slightly nerve-racking I really like
with a soundtrack yeah really well put
together do you guys still get
butterflies before filming those big
moments we are clearly feeling really
comfortable just quite cute and each
other when you're filming so I think our
first one back in season four I think I
did I think I missed maybe
well there's just always so many people
on set as well you know there's actually
30 people in the room so it's and it can
be quite technical there's already
chopped up and there's a bit more yeah
but I think the montage is sweet because
I think it really shows you know
obviously you have such different
relationships in the show and it's nice
that we have three completely different
ages and relationships and circumstances
and outcomes of those seen a nob John at
the end of it I thought that was really
funny
I liked I thought it was I thought that
was a really nice
torn the way that they do all of that
together yes can we say about that love
is a love montage but it's Outlander I
mean you're given the fans what they
asked for
yeah
[Music]